[Music]
in the best landlord ever news
oh I'd um water this german housing
complex hasn't raised its Gwent in 500
years 500 years yeah I thought I'd
blocked out the Australian last time so
this time I would bring you a different
one all right good luck enjoy it what do
you think I didn't understand this
German housing complex hasn't raised its
rent in 500 years
oh it's impressive that there's a
housing complex that existed for 500
years wait how much do they charge like
10 cents so they do charge bread like
less than a dollar a year a year is it
waiting lists like long as [ __ ]
they're stupid cuz they did not they did
not just for inflation that's why
they're giving a big fu to inflation so
cuz they're just still charging the
exact same rent that they've charged
since the baby [ __ ] themselves yeah
they're not yes explain you me it was
founded in 1514 by this very affluent
businessman named Jacob Fuger so his
family moved to Germany in the mid 14th
century and then they established a very
well textile business and then by the
16th century that family was one of the
richest in Augsburg and then they
expanded to real estates and banking and
at one point Jacob was the wealthiest
banker in the city if he was alive today
with like counting inflation he would be
worth two hundred and seventy seven
billion dollars like he was [ __ ] rich
back then oh wow he used to have this
personal newspaper that was printed out
only for his eyes every week and he
would have pretty much like cheese Mayo
like other businessmen
wait so there was a whole news team just
just for him just for him to read that's
how rich I want that's crazy so he had
like journalists and all these guys in
the whole [ __ ] company just to print
up remember this was back in 1514 that's
sick though that means you have a whole
hire teamm to print out one paper for
you in this paper he was trying to get
like secrets of like his his competitors
and stuff like that I like this guy
Julie at one point he saw some rumors
about himself in his own newspaper
saying something along the lines of like
people all started seeing him as a
greedy person so he wanted to do
something really nice for the people and
so what he did is he decided to open up
this housing complex for the very very
poor and so he is only requirements is
that three times a day you need to pray
to that family and this is still to this
day one dollar a year but back then it
was a different kind of currency but it
pretty much comes out to 88 Euro cents
which is about a dollar a year and there
has to be a curfew at 10 p.m.
so you have to follow those rules and
that's how you were able to say those
are the only rules yeah oh and another
rule is that you have to be a resident
at least two years in osburgh before you
can apply to become a resident there so
these foreigners don't come in and just
use all the stuff yes locals only sorry
the last one I just remembered and you
have to be dirt poor with zero debt I
love that how do you validate dirt poor
I don't know you have to be very very
poor they have a criteria are you dirt
poor hell yeah I'll turn and you can't
have a credit card even though if you're
poor you're most likely need one well
that's interesting
do we have any pictures of what the
place looks like you have to be a
Catholic faith so three times they just
keep adding roles death yeah mommy knows
part of the prank ever it's just so so
they get on their feet yeah and so it's
been around for five hundred years and
till this day no one's had to pay more
than that for a round would you stay
there forever because of the amount of
money he had back then like it's still
like that family is still well up she's
growing Wow
so they just put it like in a trust and
it's just paying for it yeah and then I
think there's like interest or something
it goes up like 2% a year so it just
keeps going with some old money right
he's a billion dollars you know yeah
well have fun never going out past 10
p.m.
well you end up coming home past 10:00
p.m. there's a small fee they have to
pay in order for them to open the gates
for you which is about a dollar so it's
um but that's all month's read not the
years I'm sorry that's a years read
year's rent not bad that's I would like
you want to go out just pay an extra
dollar that's it I'd become Catholic yep
yeah hell yeah
it's the nightlife like an owl spell I
don't need to go out I got a dollar e
I'll save up all that money yeah so now
this is like a touristic place because
people have been hearing about how old
this place is and now they charge for
euro to enter in like visitor so now
there's 67 houses and 147 apartments and
its home to 142 residents I'm sure you
guys a video clip of what it's like in
one week this time of course we had no
euro we had the real English Gilda and
they always translated this currency
into the next currency yeah Kapooka the
rich wanted to give crafts families who
had been impoverished of no fault of
their own the chance to get out of
poverty again the story of the super
family 7 son of a poker all / blue and
became the most famous banker trader
merchant of the world they called him
the first capitalist and the rich who
wrote into this donation letter for the
fog arrived
you should come behind him to take care
that this super I so it's a small
eternity that's tight there just for the
name
he was a [ __ ] billionaire at five in
five hundred years ago and his family
still has the money today pioneered
capitalism that's crazy you got to be
pretty wealthy to do that yep I don't
know how much it was worth
easily equivalent of a billionaire back
there Dez nuts
there's Japanese corporation families
that are that old to that's still around
today like a lot of these businesses
they're a Kangol your family because you
have a single essential I can never say
that word but like a family crap oh yeah
well we all have family crests like
everyone has family crest like your
family and chickens have family crest I
think we do have something like that am
I telling us yeah cuz I didn't think we
would have one and then she's like what
are you talking about we have one I'm
like what the [ __ ] did she takes off her
[ __ ] jacket and there's a [ __ ]
tattoo on her back the house crest the
house of so not any crazy dude I know I
know Guam a nians have their like like
family crest what is it climene Ian
Thomas well it's the tattoo yeah well my
Guamanian homies they have it tattooed
on them they had their family crest so
it's pretty dumb I was one one I don't
how many quests are don't you know you
said that I pictured you know the they
make thought pieasant [ __ ] yeah I always
get squeezes people asking me like God
does your family own this the crap did
you hear about my life going up you
[ __ ] I know
videos more like girl I'm out humpy dope
if the Tapatio family their family crest
is the Tapatio man with the freaking
[ __ ] logo I would not mind it you
know for some reason when you tell me
your mom told you had a family Chris I
just picture your mom going up to a
bookshelf and then pulling something
down door open oh that's nice look into
you thank you what bar would probably
figured that she said it's [ __ ] she's
crouching she's like a fool you [ __ ]
stupid he pictures you know the ass that
everyone used to draw oh yeah it's a
[ __ ] Corona bottle we all know that
ass yeah who's Stu see the one that's
three lines like this and the people and
you can make the sideways and it's super
cool and you thought it was super cool I
just remember kids drawing it on the
table and every single table had one
yeah yeah my name starts with an S I
would always like I'm draw the and then
I would like try to finish it you can do
it the lines but ya know we should
chemists that like how do you is there
Chinese family crests I mean technically
you could start your own yeah you could
do it so why can't we
yeah I guess I'm just gonna be a
dumpling in a pizza I'm curious how far
does it go back in Japanese culture and
you can every class had one like farmers
have one whatever had when it was there
it was their family trait thing I don't
know when it started but then that would
be the same thing as a logo so they used
their last name as the company name and
then the logo and then when they created
companies that was like a second family
have you looking into your ancestry yeah
my last name is actually so a lot of
people's last names can come from a
company because that was your family you
guys work together or whatever so Jitsu
Kawa was a it was like a like a fishing
company so I don't think that was you
just took on the name of the company but
my bat family wasn't the originators of
that there was someone else that made it
up yeah and also names can be or can be
given to you it they used to use it as a
status symbol so like let's say like a
warlord or whatever of a high stature
would come and be like okay you guys
been making a lot of
for my area and then so to celebrate you
you're gonna we're gonna upgrade your
name so based off of what your name was
dependent on where you were in society -
yeah so old folks that understand this
stuff they can trace back they could
read your name and it'll be like oh yeah
you're you're like a your family was a
farming family or like your family they
specialized in growing [ __ ] beets
yeah it means the river of truth so yeah
yeah and in some I'd on my dad's side it
was mama which is in front of the gates
and then so that was like like that's a
that's a warrior class so warrior class
and then they'll be like specifically
what would it be
they'll be like oh he was a bodyguard
for this warlord or this yeah and then
that's how far back it went but I don't
know beyond that like when it first
started I don't make sense where you
like weapons haha
[Music]